das nennt man wohl eine deklassierung
die hier im qualifying mercedes schlägt
ferrari durch wieder mal auf der pole
position nicht so weit vor bottas seinem
teamkollegen aber dann der abstand lag
lag mehr als 0,6 zehntel pro sekunde und
sebastian vettel der zweite ferrari
fahrer erst auf der siebten position das
ist kein guter tag für ferrari
die aus meiner sicht alt ausgesehen
haben heute obwohl sie ja ein
runderneuertes auto präsentierten mit
neuem frontflügel neuem heckflügel neuem
unterboden und anderen details aber
insgesamt ist der schritt den sie
eigentlich machen wollten ja auf
mercedes zu eigentlich so der erste
ansatz für die wende im kampf um den
titel
der ist nicht gelungen das muss man so
knallhart sagen und das ist natürlich
auch sehr bedauerlich denn es läuft ein
bisschen darauf hinaus dass der grand
prix ja zu einem werk stuhl wird
zwischen hamilton sehr stark aber erst
sozusagen im letzten moment wie üblich
bei ihm und bottas sehr stark am freitag
schon auch am samstag auch im dritten
qualifying aber eben nicht so stark dass
er hamilton dann noch einmal paroli
bieten konnte %
könnte man davon ausgehen dass es morgen
spannend wird das wird seine chance
suchen
denn er muss auch darauf achten dass der
abstand zu hamilton nicht zu groß wird
und ne clark hat angekündigt dass er die
stärke des ferraris ausspielen will auf
den langen geraden es gibt ja hier zwei
und besteht durchaus die chance dass er
in den ersten runden vielleicht vorbei
kommt und dann das tempo diktieren kann
das ist überhaupt interessant dass
ferrari auf einer strecke die 2 grad so
weit zurückfällt aber das hängt damit
zusammen dass wir dieser kurs in
frankreich korsika sehr viele
verschiedene kurven variationen hatten
in denen mercedes eben sehr stark was
wiederum zeigt ja wie alltagstauglich
wenn ich das so sagen darf dieses auto
ist überraschend unter den ersten zehn
ist das auftauchen von einem alten
berühmten bekannten mclaren auf den
positionen fünf und sechs also noch vor
vettel knackt verstappen im red bull das
zeigt dass mclaren auf einem wirklich
guten weg ist übrigens auf fünften rang
länder neu ist ein sehr junger brite
sehr erfolgsversprechend
was das aber für das rennen morgen heißt
nein mclaren wird wahrscheinlich bis
alles rund läuft da nicht viel
mitzureden haben vettel hat
wahrscheinlich bei einem guten start und
einer guten ersten runde die chance noch
nach vorne zu kommen und wie gesagt wenn
er glücklich ist wenn er vorne
reinfahren kann
wie ihr vielleicht auch mal wieder ein
ferrari sieg zumindest ist das sozusagen
die hoffnungen von ferrari auch
bundestag ist wie ihr ferrari geben
nicht auf
[Musik]